こんにちは
徳田はじめです今年の夏は
暑いいつからこんな熱いことになって
しまった
行くわ正直もうドクターはじめ気象予報士
の資格持ってるんですけれどもここ数年で
日本の気候日本の夏
猛暑非常に大きく変化しております今年の
最高気温は59°c最低気温
57度こんな暑い中で我々人類は生きて
いけるのかいいな
無理なんですもう暑すぎてびっくりもう外
にいることが間違いと
断定できるくらいの猛暑日が続いており
ます皆さん元気に生活していますでしょう
かドクター初めはもう無理だ暑すぎて無理
なので妖怪のお家の裏庭に今いるんです
けれども
今日は暑くて暑くて仕方がないプールに
入りたいでも普通のプールじゃつまらない
普通のプールならぬスライム
プールそれもあの子供用のちっちゃい
プールのレベルではない超巨大
2500リットルスライムプール作りたい
と思います
[拍手]
2500リットルどれくらいすごいか説明
しよう皆さんがよく入っているお風呂結構
たくさんお湯たまってますよね
浴槽に入ってるお湯の量って平均200L
ぐらいらしいんですよつまりお風呂12個
分
お風呂12個分のプール今日作ってみたい
と思いますものすごい大量の材料を準備し
ました早速作っていきましょう
[音楽]
まずは材料を集めてこようスライム作りに
一番必要なもの洗濯のりまずは洗濯のり
1000L準備します
持っていきます
[音楽]
1個200リットルです1000リットル
洗濯のりをドラム買って買いました
待って
[音楽]
軽いお願いします
[拍手]
L×5000L準備しました
次に超巨大プールを準備します
巨大プールに洗濯のり1000リットル
入れます
見たことないよ色が
ちょっと
濁ってる
[音楽]
怖い
ちょっとやられちゃった
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばい
ちょっとこぼしちゃいましたこれはプール
に入れていきたいと思います入れます
お願いします
重すぎて無理でしたバケツリレーで洗濯
のり入れていきたいと思いますお願いし
ます
[拍手]
来い来ます
入れ終わりましたどうでしょう
[音楽]
なんか
エロい
ただ洗濯のり放置しておくとどんどん乾い
ちゃうので次はこの洗濯のりと同じ量水を
入れてきます1000リットルです
さあ水が来ましたこれで100リットルな
んでこれを10回です
[音楽]
混ぜなきゃこれで洗濯のりと水を混ぜ
ながらこのようにします
はい
水瀬L入りましたこれで今このプールの中
に2000Lの液体ができましたこれを今
から全部
けいすけの実家に入れてみたいと思います
水と洗濯のりを混ぜていきます
すみっことかに寄りやすいのでこうやって
混ぜてあげます結構ねいい感じのいい感じ
のトロトロ感ですね次にこの液体に色を
つけていきますもちろん色はスライムから
黄緑ですこれを適量入れていきましょう
適量って何この量ちょっと
わかんないですけどもとりあえず
黄緑色になればいいので入れていきたいと
思い
ますし
[音楽]
ます
こういう感じね1本入れても全然色が
変わらないこれは大量に入れる必要があり
ますねじゃあ入れてきますちょっと足りる
かなこの量のスライム使ったことないから
なんか行けそう行けそう
[音楽]
ちょっと一回混ぜてみます
混ぜてどうなるかが大事な気がするきます
おーすごいすごい
結構発色してる気がする
どんどん入れていきます
全部入れ終わったのであとは混ぜます
混ぜてどれくらい色がつくかですね
[音楽]
よしいい色になってきたぞ結構
綺麗な黄緑色になってきましたこれで
スライムの第1段階を終了ですここから第
2段階に移っていく
次にホウ砂を40キロ準備しましたこんな
量のホースで準備したことない
40kgを500Lのお湯に溶かしていき
ます
危ない粉です絶対言っちゃダメ
溶かしていきます
[音楽]
ご覧ください500
L準備しましたこれを今からこの中に
ぶち込んで
混ぜれば
完成です
2,500リットルのスライム作っていき
ましょうここからはいかに俺が混ぜるか
放置すると硬いスライムになるのでここ
からスピードです本気出します
[音楽]
ください
結構
[音楽]
固まってきましたもう少しで完成です
[笑い]
液体の部分が多分まだ混ざってなくてこう
いう重なってない部分がまだ結構あるんで
もうちょっと入れていきます
[音楽]
[笑い]
ちょっと気持ちいい
[音楽]
完成しました
というわけで完成しました2500
リットルのスライムプールスライムブロー
よりはるかに大きいスライムプールです
思っ
[音楽]
て
まとまりつき方もすごすぎて見てください
これ
ほらちゃんとしっかり買ったこれ大丈夫
ビンタみたいな
ちゃんとスライム完成しました
ちょっと
飛び込んでみましょうか
さあいよいよ完成しました2500
リットルのスライムプール私はかつて
スライムブローを作ったことがありますが
それをはるかに凌駕する量ですそこに今
飛び込んだ
跳ねる水しぶきスライムの感触はいかほど
かなんだか表情が痛そうださあ次はどう
いう飛び方をするのか一気に高くジャンプ
して足を振り上げてそのまま
落下する
おとしから入ったこのアングルでも見てみ
ましょう高くジャンプして足から飛び込む
気持ちよさそうなのだろうか次のジャンプ
です次は頭から行っちゃう感じですね何と
もダイナミックな飛び方大丈夫なのかそれ
はでもすれば柔らかい大丈夫ビター頭から
いった気持ち
良さそうだ
次は最高の勢いでジャンプしてみましょう
かなり助走をつけてジャンプだ高い高い足
が汚れているがそのままケツからスライム
に飛び込む
ビシャーンと入った
しぶきがヌルヌルしていってるあれこれ
本当に気持ちいいのかなんか若干痛そうな
顔してますけども実際はどうなのでしょう
か普通のスピードで見てみましょう
はいじゃあ2500リットルのスライム
ちょっとすごいなこれ
でも
ちょっとは
プールが小さすぎやしないですかねこん
だけ厚みがあればもっと大きいプールに
入れれるのではないでしょうかというわけ
でこちらが
プール準備されて入れていきます
ではスライムをこっちに移動していきます
合計2500kmです
[音楽]